SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER IN ONE MINUTE. SO
PLEASE COME DOWN TO ROOM 1200.
IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WOULD
LIKE TO GET STARTED. WE HAVE ONE
BILL, AND THE AUTHOR IS PRESENT.
SO IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE, PLEASE COME DOWN TO
ROOM 1200. SO THAT WE COULD HEAR
FROM THE ONE AUTHOR AND VOTE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
WHATEVER YOU WANT. I'M SORRY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER.
WE ARE OFFICIALLY IN ORDER. SO
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME. WE
HAVE ONE MEASURE ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY. WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM, SO WE WILL NOT CALL THE
ROLL QUITE YET. THIS IS BILL
NUMBER AB 440 FROM PELLERIN AND
BLAKE SPEER. AND I INVITE YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN, TO
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT THE
BILL. PLEASE THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
YES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, GOOD TO SEE
SOME FOLKS HERE TODAY, AB 440
ENSURES THAT THE EDUCATION AND
CLIMATE BOND MEASURES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING THIS
WEEK ARE ABLE TO APPEAR ON THE
NOVEMBER'S GENERAL ELECTION
BALLOT. WITHOUT THIS BILL, THOSE
MEASURES LIKELY WOULD NOT APPEAR
ON THE BALLOT UNTIL JUNE 2026.
AB 440 ALSO PROVIDES CLARITY TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ON THE
PLACEMENT AND NUMBERING OF
LEGISLATIVE BALLOT MEASURES FOR
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND CUTS
DOWN ON THE NUMBER OF BALLOT
MEASURES THAT VOTERS ARE ASKED
TO DECIDE. THIS NOVEMBER BY
MOVING ONE LEGISLATIVE MEASURE
TO THE 2026 BALLOT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
WHEN YOU GET A COMMITTEE. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WHO ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES,
PRIMARY OR WISHING TO TESTIFY?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE WILL MOVE
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS FOR ANY
DISCUSSION. ANY MEMBERS WISHING
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS NØ. SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELTON, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WHEN YOU HAVE
YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE? I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. SO THE MOTION
WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION,
BUT IT WILL BE DUE PASS GOING
STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVE A GREAT DAY.
OKAY. WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE NOW HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS TO DO SO. SO, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
BLAKE'S HERE PRESENT. BLAKE'S
HERE. PRESENT. WHEN HERE. WHEN
HERE. ALAN. MENGIBAR HERE.
MENGIBAR HERE. NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HERE.
UMBERG THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON AB 440? MOVE IT. OKAY.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES AB 440,
WHICH IS DO PASS, AND THE
MEASURE WILL GO STRAIGHT TO THE
FLOOR. SO, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE
SPEAR, A BLAKE SPEAR. AYE. WHEN
NO ONE. NO. ALAN MENGIBAR. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
UMBERG DO YOU WANT IS ON CALL.
IT'S THREE ONE AND IT'S ON CALL.
SENATE ELECTIONS IS COMING BACK
TO ORDER. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL LIFT AND CALL ON FILE.
ITEM ONE, AB 440. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. CHAIR I VICE CHAIR VOTED
NO. ALAN NEWMAN, UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE THANK YOU. IT'S FOUR ONE.
IT'S ON CALL. IT'S THE ONLY
BILL, RIGHT? YEP OKAY, GREAT. SO
LET'S LET'S LIFT THE CALL ON THE
ONE ON ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 440.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS ALAN I ALAN,
I NEWMAN, IT'S FIVE ONE. IT'S
FIVE ONE. IT WILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL.
OKAY. WE'RE. WE'RE LIFTING THE
CALL ON ITEM ONE FIVE. ITEM ONE,
AB 440. MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
CHAIR, VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE Ó. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT IS SIX
ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT. AND
THIS COMMITTEE IS OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED.